i've carried most of my life the sense
of failing every woman i interact with
will smith is getting candid like never
before admitting that he feels like he's
failed every woman in his life
really at the end of the day
it's
just not quitting you know the actor
sits down with oprah winfrey during
friday's episode of the oprah
conversation on apple tv plus and opens
up about his new memoir his deepest
insecurities biggest life lessons and
marriage
there's something about you now i want
to tell the truth i want to let people
have it and in a sneak peek at the chat
it seems safe to say it's no holds
barred i'm laying on the floor in a jail
cell and i'm like what is happening
i haven't talked about that publicly
that must have been some family meeting
and while the 53-year-old
multi-hyphenate has had a lot of success
he reveals one area where he's felt
failure i've carried most of my life the
sense of failing every woman i interact
with this all comes a day after a new
excerpt was released from the fresh
prince of bel air star's new memoir will
where he admits he fell in love with his
six degrees of separation co-star
stockard channing while working on the
1993 film while he was newly married to
his first wife cherie zampino
cheri and i were in the first few months
of our marriage with a brand new baby
and for cherie i can imagine that this
experience was unsettling to say the
least and to make matters worse during
shooting i fell in love with stockard
channing will adds that his marriage to
cherie was off to a quote rocky start
and after filming on the movie wrapped
he found himself quote desperately
yearning to see and speak to stockard
etie was there in 1993 when will was
promoting the film he praised stockard
for helping him prepare for the role
what was great with stocker channing she
was able to give me insight into how
a lot of different people have done the
characters as for cherie who shares a 28
year old son trey with will she told et
back in 2020 why she doesn't mind living
with the label of will smith's ex-wife
you know
it's not my label
and i can't control the labels that
other people you know put on me but the
reality is that is a part of my history
you know it's a part of my history but i
don't i'm not behind anybody i'm not in
anybody's shadow
and um so i i don't i don't mind like it
could be worse the marriage didn't work
but we are a success
you know the love that we have for each
other the the co-parenting journey and
and not doing it perfectly but being
effective and being an example for other
people so we're we're i'm i'm i'm a part
of his greatest success and in a clip
from the upcoming chat with oprah will
opens up about finding love after
heartbreak
god put the greatest things in life on
the other side
of your worst fears
you know and they're being able to step
into those fearful places
you know love
being the most fearful place you'll ever
try to step into that unconditional love
where you know to be able to open a
broken heart again
[Music]
you